this is Startalk all right let's move on
to Victoria Hughie coming to us from
Earth okay okay they're theoretically
dr. Tyson do you think a superhero with
the power of inter universal travel
could ever be truly possible or with the
probability of the laws of physics in
other universes being different from
ours prevent that from ever happening
could somebody do it
awesome question so in the multiverse
concept yes these were by the way in
Thor that is what happens
it is the inter universal travel because
Thor opens away from his world opens up
a portal no no his world
I think his world is in our universe he
just the portal gets you from his multi
part of it all right so they isn't isn't
that world sectors and we're one of
those sectors I think it is okay all
right you're right there's six sectors
right one of them we're one of them and
so this is easy access from one sector
so that's a wormhole that's a wormhole
it's essentially one but this would be
an inter universal portal from the my
gotcha so in the multiverse it's it's
prescribed by the fact that these are
fluctuations in the quantum early
quantum universe all right and quantum
physics is a fascinating understanding
of the structure of matter on the
smallest scales right there is there's
particles that pop in and out of
existence I mean it's a stunning reality
that exists at those scales now the
whole universe doesn't do that
unless the entire universe were the size
of an atom then when you pop particles
in and out of existence you're actually
popping universes in and out of
existence whoa now see man now I wish I
had some marijuana cuz that is the
awesome but you just said man I should
be high right now that would be so cool
here's my question because that would
mean why well here's my question that
fact is so profound will the marijuana
add to it or subtract no marijuana is
definitely gonna add
because I when I think of marijuana I
think of something that adds depth to
something that doesn't otherwise have it
that is also true than what I'm saying
how well I'm handing you depth on a
silver platter and now what it can also
do is augment the depth that is already
present and thought about the augment
yes so you know it can work both ways it
can make you look at something to go
whoa when you shouldn't be doing that at
all right you know I mean just like oh
my god you put coffee in that coffee cup
oh my god that is so frigging awesome
you mean it's a container completely
devote it to just one liquid oh my god
coffee coffee whoa sane or it could take
something that is already mind-blowing
uh and then just cause you to get even
deeper into that okay like the fact that
popping in and out of the multiverse on
a quantum physics level with me that we
are the atom that's popping in and out
right the whole universe if your atom
does it pop it see that is awesome yeah
so here you have it so now it turns out
our understanding quantum physics tells
us that if you pop a new universe out of
this right the laws of physics will
likely be slightly different okay okay
so all this ensemble of other universes
are could be dangerous to visit right
crossing from one universe to the other
and clearly the person who wrote that
question understands this absolutely
this area you would have to be a
superhero who had law of physics
resistant molecules that you were
composed of right so maybe there are
certain configurations of matter and
energy that transcend even the
multiverse itself sweet then you'd make
a super hero out of this super substance
so that it could visit different
universes and save people in all the
different universes but none no one of
us could do that right because you could
fall into a pile of goo right despite
just by popping out just by popping in
because then the forces that bind your
molecules manifest differently from one
one universe to another so there would
be an it would be an excuse to invent a
new kind of substance out of which he
would make this new kind of superhero
and this new kind of superhero would
actually be a new kind of physics -
because just like quantum physics is
different he would be the quantum
physics of the multiverse cuz he's
different uh he be different yeah but
but what's interesting is if you can
make everything out of stuff that's
different then it wouldn't matter what
universe you were in last room yeah but
you'd have to know how to interact with
the stuff that isn't different that's
the that's the fun part
see this is why we need a marijuana man
this will tell you right now this is
Startalk